are you just gonna sit there and watch
me play yeah dead cells like this are
you ready yeah I would say I was born
ready
I was I was not born ready
[Music]
dead cells came out in early access last
year May of 2017 as of today of this
recording it is officially out on switch
as you're playing right now on this bad
boy
ps4 Xbox one PC PC later today I believe
but regardless it's on every platform in
its full version from motion twin studio
based in Bordeaux France this game is
unreal a lot of people reviews too
started coming out today is getting
nines all over the place people really
like this game including us including a
lot of people in the office first I want
to start off I personally think if
you're gonna play dead cells and you
have a switch that's the platform to
play it on I think this game fits it
especially well because of its roguelite
elements you can pick up dead cells and
if you die within 10 minutes you can put
it down and maybe you gain a few more
cells that you can contribute to more
health potions or you could sit down and
like blow through the game in a weekend
if you wanted to when it's docked have
you been playing primarily on the switch
so I played on PC when it first came out
on know when it first came the early
access but pretty early but since I
didn't play it at all after that and
then I've just been playing on switch
and I agree I think it's perfect on
switch because it has that sort of long
progression in terms of you want to like
slowly work towards these skills that
carry over through each run but then
each run I mean depending on how good
you are they can last two minutes they
can last 30 minutes I've had some go
almost an hour I haven't finished it yet
I think I'm getting pretty dang close
but it is a dick thing that's very
addicting that's a thing like each time
you play a new playthrough so to speak
there's the aspect of gold which lets
you buy pretty good weapons upfront if
you run into a merchant or if you come
up to a checkpoint or if you want to buy
a new bow or some sort an upgrade but
then there's cells
[Music]
which the titular currency that lets you
buy permanent upgrades so when you start
the game you don't have health potions
you just have your health unless you
find food your health is gonna keep the
winning at a steady pace but once you
actually unlock one health potion your
next playthrough you'll have that health
potion you can just if it works like
this blast it's like a nest as fast
exactly a default thing to say is that
ex game is like Dark Souls in this
regard but that sells does have that
element of if you die you lose your
cells and those are the most valuable
currency because they give you permanent
upgrades but it also makes this like
there's this really intense moment right
before you die we're like I'm about to
lose like 40 cells that I could put
toward a really good upgrade maybe this
upgrade gives me a very good bow right
at the beginning of the game did you
feel like as you're playing through the
game it balances out kind of like yes
there's the procedural generation and
like it's it varies each time you play
but do you feel like there's still like
a good through line when you're actually
upgrading permanently or whatever like
you feel like that's pulling you through
as well yeah totally just being able to
seeing your progress tick by as you get
to each I forget their call they're like
handlers or something like that yeah and
you kind of just invest cells and
different things that's really cool but
I think the biggest draw for me is how
diverse you can build your character on
each run each power scroll you come
across you can invest in three different
three different tiers you can do
brutality which is just melee weapons
you do tactics which are more like yeah
they're color-coded jets yeah and then
there's survival which it's kind of a
mix of gadgets and like health regen
depending on the perks you pick and then
also you could be you base that off of
the items you find to throughout your
run so you could have completely
different character builds just over the
course of an hour one character could be
like spear and crossbow that another
person can be a mage who has daggers or
something like that and I really love
how how how many different options there
are and how it's totally chance you
might get it you might not get it but
you can also kind of you can invest your
cells and two into have things going
your favor like you can have certain
specific weapons unlock for you so they
kind of go in the rotation
despite the bet the fact that the game
seems pretty simple there's a lot to
keep track of like you mentioned you can
have two gadgets equipped two weapons
like shield ranged or melee then you get
mutations each time you get to a
checkpoint which are just by and large I
think almost all them are passive
abilities and then of course you have
cells to buy a permit upgrades you have
money to buy temporary there's a lot of
things going on and that's the last
thing I wanted to ask you about I think
this game meshes kind of mashes genres
together really well because there are
Metroidvania aspects there's like those
permanent abilities you get like you
tickle those plants that grow vines or
those coffins that you can use to
teleport around there are like permanent
navigational abilities
yeah then again completely changed the
areas that you get to and like the ways
you're gonna get to certain bosses yeah
so do you feel as if it balances
Metroidvania of rogue lights 2d action
like I said kind of dead cells currency
or hollow Knight if you want to look at
a more recent similar game do you think
it balances all those well or did you
feel like maybe kind of one of the
aspects felt like an afterthought or
what no I think all three of those
aspects tie in perfectly and on paper it
almost doesn't sound like it does like
that sounds like a lot they're trying to
tackle but I think it does everything
well and I think there is a lot to take
into account and I think when you first
start that is definitely an issue like
you can be overwhelming especially when
like you go through all this and they're
like okay now you gotta pick your perk
or whatever your passive ability and
earn your mutation and it's like what
like what does this do but I think if
you just kind of commit to it and just
let yourself figure it out naturally
things start to fall into place and when
you get in a rhythm and you figure out
progression combat like the different
weapons you can combo off of each other
it becomes so satisfying yeah as opposed
to like this this game is like the
definition of like a mile deep puddle or
whatever the metaphor is like some like
you know you can have open-world games
that are as wide as an ocean but as deep
as a pothole or whatever this is the
opposite this is like so dense with
things like there's even the idea that
if you are if you're in a later
playthrough and you're want to rush
through and get to those doors that have
timers on them which at first you're
like why would I even want to do that
but then later on you start to get
useful upgrades and so you don't have to
like
slowly go through the beginning of each
playthrough once you're really far into
the game there's a lot to consider
within like the first five minutes of
each of each playthrough and I think
this game does a phenomenal job of
cramming so much quality content into
like such a small sphere so to speak as
opposed to like just like kind of being
too ambitious and being scatterbrained
all over the place but like now that
games officially out on four platforms
and not just early access like it was
last year I think like everybody should
try it I think in my opinion this is
essential viewing so to speak whatever
platform you have because no matter what
platform you have you could play this
now unless you just don't like a 3ds
yeah and like you said playing on switch
is wonderful yeah it is so perfect for
switch but if you don't have a switch I
still recommend it it's up there for
like number two or three my favorite
games of the year so for me to
[Music]